How do we fix this? How do you fix it number one?
You need to identify what it is to start as you start making some of you don't know what it is
By the way, you listen this like I don't know what it is. That's good. You haven't made enough offers
That's your first problem. If you don't know what your thing is, you need to start doing more shit
You're not asking enough people for enough money. You're not doing enough calls
Okay, once you do enough calls, you're gonna figure out real quick. What that thing is for you. Now, here's how you solve it
very simply
You start doing the very thing you're asking people to do
If you keep getting I need to talk to my partner. I
Need to talk to my wife
Go talk to your partner. Go talk to your wife. Hey partner. Hey wife. Do you trust me?
If something comes across my desk, that's at least actually, you know, whatever blah blah blah blah. Are you good if I make that decision?
Yes or no, okay, cool get on the same page overcome it if you have an issue with contracts
You got to unfuck your mind because guys life is contracts you have a house you have a car you have a cell phone you have
All these different things like life is literally contracts
Okay, if you have an issue with price you need to get around people that are spending more money
You need to get around people that are making more money
You need to quit going with people that when they choose where they're gonna eat
They're thinking of where can I get a meal for five bucks because they're broke as shit
Okay, you need to go sit down with somebody that goes and they don't even look they get the appetizer
They get the bottle of wine they get the frickin dessert
They get they just look at what they want and now your mind is gonna start to expand like, okay
Yeah, that's actually not that much thousand bucks not that much. I just spent three hundred dollars on dinner
Okay thousand bucks is nothing
That's how you overcome it. So my challenge to you guys this and then we're gonna jump into QA is
Whatever first of all, if you don't know what that objection is for you, you're not making enough offers
You need to do that first
But if you do know the objection if you want to overcome that and quit getting that you need to fundamentally
overcome this in your head and
The way that you do that is by doing the thing that you keep facing by signing the contract
Okay by making the decision same day
By doing it without your wife or your husband or your partner
Okay
Now again strategically by not worrying about buying something because it's too expensive because you know what money's money and I'm gonna make it back
Okay, that's how you overcome it